- I can't wear fragrance
because I have sensitive skin.
If I could, (man laughing) I wouldn't mind
like a grilled meat fragrance.
I really love it.
(funky, bass-thumping music)
- Hey, guys!
In college, I used to work at Chipotle.
Today, I'm bringing Chipotle to BuzzFeed.
That's right, I'm bringing my burrito hack
straight to my co-workers
to see what they think.
I honestly think it is the
best combination of sweet,
savory, salty, spicy,
and
chipotle all in one.
(rhythmic, energetic music)
- Exactly, man.
See, I come here all the time.
- Damn right it does.
(rhythmic, energetic music)
- Chipotle is probably my
favorite place in the world.
For a long time, I think my record was
I went 26 times in a month.
- What!
- I think that's the best I ever did.
- That's almost every single day.
- My Chipotle opinion is
that Dos Toros is better.
- No offense to Dos Toros but
you can't replace Chipotle.
(funky, rhythmic guitar music)
(funky, rhythmic bass-thumping music)
- [Woman] Oh, damn!
- There Is a lot of guac in here.
- Yeah, there's a (beeping) lot of guac.
- Geez.
- I know guac is extra.
I never forget
so this is a treat.
- They won't let you forget.
(laughing)
- It looks like something I would eat
by myself.
- I just wanna know what
to do with this lemon.
Is it like a shot?
Do you take a bite then
you suck on the lemon
like tequila?
- No.
- Before you take a bite,
you must squeeze the
lemon unto the burrito.
(hammer pounding)
Squeeze, eat, repeat.
- I'm impressed 'cause a lifetime
of drinking lemon water there
and I never thought the lemon
would be part of the meal.
- I'm nervous.
- So squeeze.
- It's going everywhere.
Ooh!
- Eat.
(perky music)
- Something sweet is in here.
I'm not mad at it.
- No.
- It's like dessert Chipotle.
- Yeah, I don't like it.
(laughing)
- Yeah, that's really good!
- I'm a fan.
- This is banging!
Especially when you get like
the zest from the lemon
like
(perky music)
this (beeping) is popping.
- I just wish it wasn't so slimy.
It's just slipping all
over my hands right now.
- Like I said, something that you do
with your close friends.
- Exactly.
- Ooh, now it's kinda like sweet and spicy
when it like sits on your tongue.
- It was definitely--
- Ooh, I like that!
- Yeah.
- The sauce is really good.
- I can feel it in the back of my throat.
(perky music)
- It's a little spicy but--
- A tiny bit.
- I'm Nigerian so it's
really not that spicy.
- A good mix of like sweet,
like a tangy zest situation happening
because of the lemon,
savory.
It's a spicy something happening
but it's not too much.
It's like the right amount of each.
It not flavor overkill.
(lively, bass-thumping music)
- This is outside-of-the-box
Chipotle work here.
- I think you're on to something.
- The sweet is perfect.
It just needs to like jack up on the spicy
just a little bit.
- Now I'm going to go to Chipotle
instead of Dos Toros.
Good job, Jade.
- Oh, yeah.
(laughing)
- In order for me to eat this,
I would remove the agave.
That's the thing that
like really threw me off.
I still love Chipotle though.
I'm never gonna give that up probably.
- I am now forever indebted
to my awesome co-worker, Jade.
- I just want to thank you for
introducing this to my life.
It's definitely changed it for the better.
- Yeah.
- Even Chipotle salads are
better than eating salad.
- Um, that's a quote.
(laughing)
(perky music)